تكمن مشكلة
قمع أسواق الأصول كثيرًا في أنك
تسببت في
حدوث تشويه كبير ، لذا فقد أراد بنك الاحتياطي الفيدرالي
أن تكون أسعار الفائدة منخفضة للغاية الآن إذا
كنت مستثمرًا ، فإن
السندات الحكومية هي السندات الحكومية بأصولك الآمنة ،
وهي كيفية التنويع
بعيدًا عن الأسهم
ولكن  إذا كان سعر السندات الحكومية
مصطنعًا كما هو الحال اليوم ، فهو مرتفع جدًا
لديك ، فهذا لم يعد وسيلة
مخففة للمخاطر بالنسبة لك ، لذا إذا نظرت في
مكان آخر بشكل طبيعي ، فستبحث عن
الذهب
ولكن المشكلة مع سوق الذهب لذلك
الكثير من الناس  دخلت في عملات
البيتكوين كمخفف للمخاطر ، الأمر الذي يبدو
سخيفًا لأن
عملات البيتكوين متقلبة بشكل لا يصدق ، لكن
هذا وضع
يكون فيه في نظر بعض
المستثمرين أقل الأصول سوءًا للاستخدام
وهذا مجرد مؤشر على
التشوهات التي
نواجهها  السوق بسبب هذا
التدخل الهائل للبنوك المركزية ،
ما هو في عينيك محمد ، هل هو
نهج استثماري مناسب كما
قلت ، إنه عقبات  الخيار السيئ
في معركة القبيح
يبدو
أنه خيار استثماري
مناسب يتعين عليك اتخاذه في هذه اللحظة
عندما لا يكون لديك خيارات أخرى ، لذا إذا
كنت تقوم بذلك
فذلك لأنك تعتقد أن
تبني القطاع الخاص سيستمر
وهو ما  أعتقد أنه الشيء الصحيح الذي يجب
تصديقه
ولكنك تعتقد أيضًا أن
الحكومات لن تتدخل في هذا الأمر
الذي لست متأكدًا منه تمامًا ،
لذلك أميل إلى إخبار الناس أن يكونوا حذرين حقًا ،
فهذه ميزة
تريد تأسيس نفسها ولكن
يمكنها فقط  تثبت نفسها
إذا سمحت الحكومات بذلك
وتسلب الكثير من الحكومات ،
فإنها تأخذ ما كان يسمى كبار
الأثرياء القدرة
على توفير العملة والاستفادة من
ذلك ، لذلك أقول للناس أن يكونوا حذرين
لأنك لا تفترض
تبني القطاع الخاص فحسب ، بل  أنت تفترض أيضًا
أنني سأحصل على تسامح الحكومة
وأنني لست متأكدًا من
أنني كنت أجري النقاش الأسبوع الماضي حول
ما إذا كانت عملة البيتكوين أكبر من أن
تفشل
أم لا ، وما إذا كان  أو لا ،
لا يزال بإمكان الحكومات التدخل والقول للشركات الخاضعة للتنظيم على
وجه الخصوص ، نريدك أن تبتعد
عن وجهة نظرك حول هذين الأمرين
الأكبر من أن تفشل واحتمال
قول المنظمين إنني آسف لأننا لا
نريد  لقد شاركت في هذا
الأمر لا يزال محفوفًا بالمخاطر في هذه المرحلة ،
لذا من منظور ضيق ، ليس من
الضخم أن تفشل
من منظور أوسع قد
يمثل تحديًا آخر لنموذج السيولة
حيث يراهن المستثمرون ببساطة على
السيولة وكما قلت سابقًا.  تعرضت
بالفعل لثلاث حوادث قريبة ، لذا عليك
أن تكون حذرًا فأنت لا تعرف أبدًا
أي أداة ثني صغيرة ستسبب تراكمًا
على الطريق السريع وهذا ما
عليك أن تكون حريصًا بشأن
معرفتك بأحد الأشياء الأخرى التي يريدها
الناس  يشيرون في هذه المرحلة
لعشاق العملات المشفرة ، لكنه يرتبط
أيضًا بالنقطة التي كنا نبينها بشأن أن أرقام الوظائف
ليست تضخمية للغاية وأن
مكون الأجور هو
نمو المعروض النقدي الذي
نشهده.  نمو عرض النقود الحبلية
وأنا أنظر على وجه التحديد إلى ما نسميه
m2 زيادة 27 عامًا بعد عام
في أرقام فبراير التي كانت
مرتفعة تقريبًا في الشهر السابق
محمد عندما يتم استخدام هذا كذريعة
أو سبب للاستثمار في
العملات المشفرة
ماذا تفعل  أنت تفعل ذلك وكيف يجب علينا
كمستثمرين عاديين أو
أفراد عاديين أن ننظر إلى هذا الرقم على وجه التحديد
كمبرر لذلك تذكر
أن لديك ثلاثة أنواع من المستثمرين في
العملة المشفرة
لديك أولئك الذين يفعلون ذلك
لأسباب دفاعية وتحدثنا عن أن
لديك أولئك الذين  افعل ذلك لأسباب مضاربة
ولكن لديك أيضًا أولئك الذين
يعتقدون حقًا أننا نخفض
قيمة العملات بسبب نمو المعروض النقدي ،
لذا فهم يفعلون ذلك لسبب إيجابي
أنهم يتبنون شيئًا
لا يمكن الحط من شأنه ، لذا كلما زاد
عرض النقود لديك '  سوف
نرى أنه كلما زاد ذلك من دفع الناس
إلى العملة ، فإن مشكلة
نمو عرض النقود هي أنه من
المنطقي
عندما يكون الاقتصاد الأمريكي  نظرًا لأن الاقتصاد الأمريكي يواجه
رياحًا
معاكسة الآن ، فإن الاقتصاد الأمريكي لديه رياح
خلفية هائلة ، ومع ذلك فإننا نستمر في
زيادة المعروض النقدي
عند هذه المستويات المذهلة ،
ولهذا السبب بدأ الناس يقولون مهلاً
انتظروا دقيقة حتى لا يتخلى الغذاء
عن المسرّع ببطء.